well I've trained with him before and  I've been amazed frankly by his his  talent and I haven't been able to play  many tournament games with him at all so  I thought it would be and you know an  excellent opportunity to find a new  challenge I was very surprised that he  requests to play against me but we have  good good relationship and somehow we  had a training camp in Qatar two years  ago he's a world champion and I have  studied he games carefully to learn  something from him well he has many  strengths he has an extreme calculating  ability he's very good at judging  dynamic positions and he also he also  has good technique so he doesn't have  many many flaws and that's why he's you  know rated 27 7080  I liked his playing style pretty much I  think my style maybe is a little bit  familiar with similar with him